you know what's nice is that this movie
is about your character and Ben
Stiller's character relationship with
their dad and and I I knew your dad I
got to know him a bit years and years
ago back in the day terrific guy I loved
doing
did you it always seemed like you guys
had a really good relation to anything
he told me to do I would do but I I
worshipped him but I never I was I don't
know why this came up but I was in the
car with my dad when I was like that's
like 11 or something oh no no I was
probably like 14 or something so I'm
sitting in his car
we're about to go in the house and I
look over my dad he's sitting he's about
to get and I go dad were you ever with
anyone before mommy and he goes what's
that and I said were you ever with
anyone before mommy goes what do you
mean and I said I go before mom did you
ever do it you know and he did you go
all the way with somebody before mommy
and my dad was trying to be honest I
think and he's like this is a moment and
he goes well on a few ladies before your
mother I practiced with I was a kid and
I was like what does that mean and then
he goes well you don't wanted to make
sure I was prepared for your mother
properly and remembers just going
I ran into the house and hug my mother
and I was like daddy your horse he was
he should have waited yeah
you